So let's take a quick look at the code query for the conference entities. So
here I am in the conference api.javafile or conferenceapifile
and the queryConferences method. So you'll notice it's declared has a at
APIMethod annotation. Name queryConferences. Path queryConferences.
And the httpMethod is HttpMethod.POST. So
the query for the conference is, you create the
query of type conference. Then you call ofy.load.type specifying the
entity class, which in this case is conference class.
And then we want to order by name. To actually
execute the query, we call the list method on
the query. And we're going to return the results of running
the query, which is going to be all the conferences,
ordered by name. And that's all there is to it.